hi there steve here to talk about
language learning again
and i want to talk today about enjoying
our language learning now i understand
that some people have a need to learn
english or german or some language for
work or for school and so they feel
pressure and they don't enjoy it but
even for those people if they can find a
way to enjoy it they're going to do
better
but no i want to comment on this because
there was someone who commented here on
my youtube channel
saying you know you've been at arabic
now for two years and you're still
talking about spending more time at it
you don't seem to be getting anywhere
what's the point or where's that effect
i didn't read the whole thing but the
gist of it was that
uh i thought that i would review uh the
amount of time that i've spent on these
different languages over the last little
while
and how i managed to enjoy them so i
will show you now my profile in arabic
and i'm going to use we have our
statistics at link i could show you
hours of listening or links created but
i'm just going to focus on words of
reading because i think the reading is
and typically when i'm reading i'm
linking or i'm reviewing but i'm reading
is a big part of learning so if we look
at my arabic profile you'll see that i
started out in january of 2018
which is over two years ago indeed
and of course the first period it went
slowly because i'm trying to get used to
the writing system and it was more or
less around november of 2019 that it
really bumps up because i'm going off to
morocco where i hope to use it
and then it fell off because i was
mixing it in with other languages
turkish and persian and now i'm starting
up again uh reading more because i'm
watching uh
levantine arabic
and egyptian arabic movies on netflix
but all the while i'm enjoying it i'm
not concerned about
what i can say how well i perform i'm
enjoying the language and i think that's
an important part of of enjoying it is
set yourself meaningful goals
if i contrast that to and i'm just gonna
pick one let's look at the persian that
i've been learning at the same time and
you'll see that my involvement with
persian is much more recent and it's
bunched up basically
heavy in sort of the spring of 2020.
but also prior to going to morocco i did
my i think i did a three month challenge
in persian
but it's a shorter period of time and it
also has its ups and downs and i enjoy
it whenever i'm into persian
if i look at you know i had a brief
fling with a turkish
so you see that that's essentially
bunched up into that
nine uh that three-month challenge that
i did back in
may june july of 2019 but i have i have
discovered i have a sense of how that
language works that's tremendously
enjoyable when my wife is watching a
turkish movie on netflix i do understand
some of it and i can always go back to
it it's not lost so i enjoy what i did
there and i enjoy the fact that i have
this sort of in my
you know database of languages that i
can go back to i'm not concerned about
what i'm able to do in turkish now some
of the languages that i learned for very
specific so just here is polish and you
see polish is entirely focused on one
short period around uh
i guess uh again the fall of 2015
haven't done much since i'd struggled to
speak it but it's there i have
30 000 words or something in polish i
can go back to it whenever i want for me
it gives me pleasure to think that i
have a sense of how that language works
if i look at for example
um
let me look at korean is one that i've
fought with for a long time and so
there's different
you know peaks and valleys over a long
period of time going back to 2010
and i still don't consider that one of
the 12 languages that i speak well
although i can carry on conversations
and i understand quite a bit and i'm
happy with what i'm able to do in korean
but i wanted to show you the
uh roman yeah let's look at ukrainian
briefly briefly here so it was very much
bunched into 2014
in the first half of 2014 when all the
events started in ukraine then i kind of
laid off it and then because i was going
to visit ukraine i
spent some more time sort of brushing up
on it
but i wanted to show the maybe the
romanian and the greek so greek we
visited greece in uh
the autumn of 2017 so i had a bit of a
run at it initially getting used to the
writing system and i really focused in
on it just before going to greek to
crete and i use it and i haven't done
much since
and
but the romanian was interesting because
that was totally
focused and i guess the point i'm trying
to make
is that whatever you do in the language
try to enjoy it don't second-guess
yourself
be happy with what you're able to
achieve you'll see with romanian it's
entirely in a three-month period then i
go to romania i use it i'm happy today i
couldn't speak the language
but i could quickly get it back so all
i'm trying to demonstrate is that
whatever you're doing with the language
don't allow people to criticize you just
enjoy what you enjoy with the language
enjoy discovering to me learning a
language is a matter of discovering a
new language how it works how they use
words so i have a sense of romanian i
have a sense of arabic i have a sense of
persian i have a sense of polish czech
is another one that i spent a lot of
time on and in my check i was listening
to czech history similarly with
ukrainian in most of these languages i
like to move to something of interest
which for me is history it's like in my
persian i have this
is simple uh you know this the
collaborator in iran is telling me the
history of iran in simple words and so
i'm doing things of interest i'm
discovering the language i'm getting
into this other world and that's good
enough i'm happy i'm happy i'm not out
there to outperform anyone
and i think the pressure we put on
ourselves to speak like a native or to
you know
refine you know the the pronunciation or
or whatever
uh
is unnecessary pressure if we keep going
keep listening and reading we gradually
acquire
new words
gradually become more comfortable in the
language it's a slow process
it's getting used to a language the
brain gets used to it the brain the
brain starts
identifying these patterns
but let it be an enjoyable process
uh appreciate what you have done
appreciate the discovery of the language
noticing things in the language
just for someone who's never done french
and you go into french and you discover
that there's a whole bunch of letters
they don't pronounce
just even to know that
uh to know that the slavic languages
don't use articles
uh but they have more complicated
approaches to
you know the clintons and the verbs of
motion and even if you can't nail those
every time but you're aware that they
exist it's part of your discovery it's
part of a sort of a window on
their culture in their world so it's all
good
so i think i just wanted to you know
i guess in response to this person
saying well you know you've been at it
for so long and you're not very good
true
but i'm enjoying it
so
i don't owe anyone anything uh and
sleep as well you push you know you
think you're an expert on language
learning and it takes you so long it
takes long arabic takes a while
especially if you're blending it with
other languages
uh it takes time and as long as you're
enjoying the process
that's fine and a link is a method that
enables me to enjoy these languages to
look up words to start in with my many
stories move from there into you know i
can bring in newspaper articles netflix
i can get podcasts transcribed and study
them so i i have this means of
discovering this world using link and i
think that's very valuable
and that's why i talk about it because i
it's something that i enjoy and
i would encourage other people to enjoy
as well including enjoying studying the
language without putting put too much
pressure on themselves thanks for
listening bye